building off of Abraham Accords as you
mentioned uh Israel Saudi normalization
there's been a lot of promising progress
towards this what does it take to uh not
allow this tragedy uh damage the
progress towards Israel solidy
normalization I think right now it's
probably not the best to think about
that I think that we want to think about
that after whatever is going to happen
is going to happen now I think right now
the number one priority for Israel has
to be to uh fully regain uh Security in
the country and then number two is to
figure out how you can like I said
eliminate or degrade uh the Hamas
capability or other Iranian threats to
make sure that you have your security
apparatus I think that the Israeli
leadership right now should proceed uh
with that and I don't think that they
should be thinking about a normalization
with Saudi at this moment um my instinct
and I've been watching this Israeli
Saudi normalization play out obviously
just speaking with people and seeing
what I've been reading um and watching
with great excitement I think it would
be a GameChanger for the region I think
it's uh it's one of Iran's worst
nightmares to have Israel and Saudi uh
Interlink together I think it'd be great
for the Saudi people from a security
perspective what they're discussing with
America would be uh very strong the
ability to you know get uh different
elements across would be incredible so
what I would say with it is that the
industrial logic um held yesterday and I
think it will hold again tomorrow so um
you know I always expect countries to
act in their interests I think that uh
the deal that's on the table right now
between uh Saudi Israel and America is
in saudi's interests it's in America's
interests and it's in Israel's interest
uh what's going to happen now though is
uh the political Dynamics are going to
shift and I think that you know as we've
seen with political Dynamics they come
and go I think um let's get through this
moment um and then I hope at the right
time that those talks will be able to
resume and conclude in an appropriate
way and you know it's funny Lex when I
was working on the US
Mexico uh agreements for the trade you
know we would have every day there
wouldd be a you know a tweet that would
go out or there would be an issue I mean
people forget how how intense it was
between um America and Mexico and I
would speak to my counterpart of Mexico
after a rough day and you know we were
working on something we're making
progress it'd get blown up and I'd speak
to them and say you know what look
they're not moving America they're not
moveing Mexico let's just you know let's
stop for today let's pick up tomorrow
and let's find a new way to bring this
forward so I would just encourage
everyone working on that not to give up
uh to keep working hard at it um and to
find a way but like I said I would take
a little bit of a pause for the time
being let's let the current situation
play out and then hopefully uh there'll
be a way for it to move forward I just
hope there's still people on the US side
picking up the phone and
calling uh UAE Saudi Arabia just as
human beings as friends as allies
and just keeping that channel of
communication going cuz I uh maybe you
can correct me but I just feel like
there's just simple human dynamics that
play out here that divisions can form
and just run away from you over simple
misunderstandings over
um just inability to see a
tragedy uh from the same perspective
because of conversations that could have
happened but didn't happen I think
there'll definitely be communication but
you know words on phone calls is is only
worth so much it's really you know trust
between people and power and obviously
when you're in a position of power you
represent your country and your
country's interests but the ability to
have trusting relationships where people
feel like they're okay taking you know
more risks to help each other uh that's
actually what's most important so
communication I hope for but uh you know
deepening and trusting relationship
uh that's what I believe makes progress
and keeps people
safe and we talk quite extensively about
the value of trust and negotiation and
just working with leaders which I think
is a fascinating conversation and you've
taught me a lot about
that